but my god day after day to see these
prowling press people you know like all
have decided that the narrative is that
Trump is some sort of Basquiat figure
you know who's just not doing anything
and that people are dying because of him
you know it's a it's a real shock and I
I don't want to say I'm grateful for him
because I think he's theirs but the
day-to-day I'm sure you feel the same
way my god
if the Trump administration went along
with what CNN MSNBC and the I'm sorry to
say unspeakable New York Times New York
Times a venue that I've always adored
and always yeah and I loved and to see
what they did what they helped enable I
just don't know I if there's any such
thing as moral culpability I think I'm
so sorry to say it again it breaks my
heart I think the New York Times is
morally culpable for what's happened to
this country today
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report reminder everybody lockdown is
more fun with friends and add free video
and podcast so please consider joining
us at Rubin report.com
and joining me today is the editorial
director at the American Institute for
Economic Research Jeffrey Tucker welcome
back to the Rubin report it's good to be
here Dave nice to see you again good to
see you again I'm sorry we're not doing
this in person but we are social
distancing like everybody else
so I guess my first question to you is
well just how you doing how you doing in
a time of social distancing and lockdown
well I'm gonna give the same answer
anybody would which is I can't believe
that this is the world we live in I
never would imagine this been three
weeks ago but somehow we're faring we're
not starving we're not dying we're
talking to people and you know I wrote a
book called the market loves you and all
I can say is the market although
bludgeoned and truncated and and it's
never been attacked like this before
maybe in the history of the world it's
still somehow working so I'm very very
grateful for that yeah that seems like
the right start to this because
throughout the last month or so you're
one of the few people I would say that
it's making some consistent sense to me
at least on Twitter and and I think
you're you're a pretty great classical
liberal thinker which is why I wanted to
have here because I want to talk about
stimulus and I want to talk about
markets and I want to talk about the
Constitution and free speech and right
to assembly and all of those things that
that I know you and I and my audience
all love so why don't why don't we start
with this which is just going off what
you just said there we seem to be more
resilient perhaps than than we thought I
mean I think if you had said to people
six months ago hey do you know that in
March and April you're gonna be shut
down locked in your house along with
virtually the rest of the world for now
going on five weeks and it could be
months after that I think people would
have thought oh there's going to be
violence oh there's going to be looting
there's gonna be
crime all of these things and yet as you
started us with we're doing okay and the
markets actually haven't completely
tanked we're going up and down but
everything is kind of working Oh Dave I
could tell you such inspiring stories I
just want to cry when I think about it
you know when I go to the grocery store
which is you know one of the things you
can do now it's a access to real life
and I go in there and I first of all
make sure to thank every single worker
there for all of their that they're
doing but I'd like to talk to the
managers about how they decide what
they're going to do that day you know
was there a run on chicken yesterday
what did you do about that you know it
was there a run on sausage what did you
do about the salads you know over here
in the deli section how you getting
toilet paper how you ration it given
that there's restrictions on private
price movements how has this changed
your lives you know and all I hear is
stories of heroism
and brilliance and and it's not just
individual brilliance its institutional
brilliance and the brilliance of the
market economy it's still working
despite everything despite being
clobbered in ways that were unimaginable
just a few months ago and if I can say
so David this brings to mind a real
paradox that's the times we're living
through right now this shutdown has
presumed the adaptability of society you
know the capacity of society to make
this radical turn to go from one life to
the other life practically overnight to
adopt it and assuming the impossible
pose and and yet the government edicts
that have come down have presumed the
impossibility of society to adapt to the
presence of pandemic disease you know
like we can adapt is that is that
adaptability do you think that
adaptability is unique to capitalism
because of the way it allows so many
people to be in the market and and
innovate and and move as things need to
be moved yeah it's it's it's
it's an embedded in the essence of a
free society where we're where people
learn to be intelligent and learn to
control their world and it but there
with people and create these market
signals that that tell us some prices
and interest in all these things I think
you know at the end of this if you're
not a libertarian you're not paying
attention because the market is were and
brilliantly and it's only not worked
when it's been when it's been hobbled
and it has been hobbled you know it was
hobbled before this crisis actually and
we can talk about all the specific ways
in which that's true I blame I don't get
I don't blame coronavirus for your
suffering right now my virus has always
been with us and always will be and and
society had developed ways to deal with
viruses medical professionals especially
have learned how to deal with viruses
and it's a challenge for any society
under any conditions the way you want
above all else is freedom and
adaptability and to decentralize
decision making in the u.s. Dave for
some reason we took a completely
different direction fortunately we
haven't shut down the stock market we
have shut down essential stores and it's
thanks to that that we're eating today
you know that we're sleeping today that
we're able to get by so is but the we
owe the fact that we're surviving
through this it's it's a hundred percent
the element of freedom that remains in
the system but Jeffrey I keep reading
all these brilliant think pieces saying
how this is the shows the failure of
libertarianism and limited government
because this if ever this is the moment
we need big government to do things and
the very people who have been calling
Trump Hitler for four years are now
demanding that he do more with his power
is am I not understanding things
properly what am I missing here Dave I
think you and I share the same
frustration the response of the left has
been alarming to me just an extent that
I find indescribable because I think
last time I was on
I myself whose warning about the danger
of the authoritarianism of Trump and and
we can get out of that I think he's made
some bad decisions here
and they stem from his let's explore all
of it for sure yeah and he they extend
from his own nationalism and and his own
liberalism really which I think you're
gonna seriously problematic but my god
day after day to see these howling
oppressed people you know like all have
decided that the narrative is that Trump
is some sort of Basquiat figure you know
who's just not doing anything and that
people are dying because of him you know
it's a it's a real shock and III don't
want to say I'm grateful for him because
I think he's mins heirs but the
day-to-day I'm sure you feel the same
way my god if the Trump administration
went along with what CNN MSNBC and the
I'm sorry to say unspeakable New York
Times New York Times a venue that I've
always adored and always yeah and I
loved and to see what they did what they
helped enable I just don't know I if
there's any such thing as moral
culpability I think I'm so sorry to say
it again it breaks my heart I think the
New York Times is morally culpable for
what's happened to this country today
and I you know I I listen to the daily
podcast and I saw the hysteria being
ramped up and they and the demands for
crackdowns and they the call for a
medieval response to this and the
demands for I don't know what you would
call it but fascist communist you know
social distancing policies and it's been
grim and shocking and I even shocked
I've been shocked I don't know what to
say
I mean so it's so interesting that
you're as concerned about the media
element as I am because it seems to me
that we're fighting two viruses right
now we we all know about the corona
virus and how to fight that but the the
misinformation virus that is now
permeating throughout the media and it's
New York Times in its Vox and its CN
and the list goes on and on is making it
almost impossible for any of us to have
what I would say is the same
conversation because we're all dealing
with different sets of information how
concerned generally are you about that
tremendously I I actually I summarized
this you have we've all been talking to
Prince and what happened but I rise at
the other day that this i plea blame
some your hucksters scientists fake
scientists I'm putting about bullying
media anti-trump media you know combined
with a panicked political class and it
was a kind of a perfect storm the three
elements came together and led to a
level of wreckage that's that's
unspeakable and I'm moral what nice hey
I have to tell you because you know for
years people have told me about the evil
of the mainstream media and I've never
really wanted to go there you know like
I'm a big believer in press freedom and
I never wanted to be one of those people
to trash the New York Times you know and
I've and actually I love the New York
Times I always have but I feel like I've
gotten a real wake-up call here a real
shock I don't know how you can be in the
mainstream press today and and be
salivating over the clicks and the views
and and and you know the amount of ad
bias that you're generating from this
while watching freedom just go down the
drain
it's it's it's it's been a shock me I
just can't I can't even describe to you
how horrifying has been to me and I to
tell you the truth I've really turned it
off I've had to if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell